bodega bro kid moves to new york city
lives in bronx for two weeks these are
the tick tocks that he makes about your
beloved every [ __ ] one i go to like
i'm walking too like they're like this
[ __ ] or like [ __ ]
like this like bro that's not a grocery
store like i'm trying to get like eggs
yogurt like
cheese like [ __ ] like that right you can
get it like look at this place
[Music]
everything you need hey let me get a
bacon egg and cheese the aki way
like you know those tick tocks like
i'm i'm [ __ ] doing it
like i've literally been to like five of
those now and like i don't know what the
[ __ ] i'm about to do for dinner
like where are the krogers and like the
whole foods at like i'm about to eat
[ __ ] like
like cereal and ramen for dinner like
what the [ __ ]
so this kid posts that he posts like two
more like connecticut kid moves to new
york and then
apparently
says some [ __ ] about his job too and
like just glows like his like nda stuff
and got fired from his job and they
think this was part of it good good
yeah i love people shooting on new york
but this guy sucks
yeah why are you so unlikable so
unlikable like you would just think like
what am i trusting this kid with in my
uh wasting my time you can find bread
eggs milk at the [ __ ] bodega [ __ ]
that yeah
they got the essentials just sure if you
see if you make fun of the bacon egg and
cheese the aki way show a shitty bacon
egg and cheese you guys don't know how
to make content talk to andrew tate
about making good content
and then maybe i'm on board yeah you're
right though like
my man is wildly unlikable i hate that
[ __ ]
like just how he talks like but that is
that is like that should be a disability
yeah
the disadvantages he's going to have in
life because he's just organically that
unlikeable he deserves some sort of
stipend or something from the government
not because
those people end up like hurting people
if he opens his mouth then that's it you
lose a stipend if he just shut the [ __ ]
up he'll be good
i hear you the moment he opens his mouth
that's what's making but also the way he
looks and the way his teeth and like his
jaw the way everything
happened
i wanted to punch him yeah
like that's the thing dude that bodega
bro got fired dude free bodega i mean
yeah [ __ ] say look there is an
abnormal amount of sweets and
carbohydrates in the bodega let's just
be honest about it right not great food
but you can make a better video i hate
that guy that's why the job fired him
they've been looking for a reason they
hate this [ __ ] oh you broke the
nda they provide a valuable service to
the community too it's not whole foods
out there it's not kroger's out there
man it's a dangerous area a lot of these
places stop being poor while you go to
the bronx [ __ ] yeah get your money up
connecticut
like real talk oh man
is there a first impression thing that
someone does that you just immediately
dislike them
oh someone on site you see him he does
one thing immediately like i hate that
guy
i gotta get this out the way bronx
you're good we're good we're
[ __ ] rocks
is there a first half in the bronx
oh why are you mad i'll be outside i was
outside
dude
yeah they're gonna fall asleep after all
them stops
come on
that is true man i remember riding the
train that [ __ ] was mad fun
oh my god ryder train was mad funny that
was the last time you were on the train
so long it's insane throughout and i
rode the train my whole life bro but
it's just a diner kid i'm a diner i'm a
regular ass regular kid he's just a kid
from manhattan bro that's just different
east village like it is what it is like
grew up around heroin addicts it's no
big deal and like arose from cup it's
not impressive dog they're too sleep to
do anything to you yeah that's true but
they're all desperate too they're all
desperate no there's some crackheads too
meth heads are dangerous and also
crackers a lot of crackers a lot of
crackheads too yeah
you missed the craziness last night in
soho though when you were walking by
this hunter biden is not robbing you dog
don't worry about that hunter biggest
got it but the people that actually need
it man they get crazy bro what do they
want from you what were they going to
take was as a kid what were they going
lessons in his father's dance studies
you can't believe a woman can run a
business bro that's [ __ ] up had a
woman ran a business in your family my
mom ran the business exactly into the
ground but
that was my dad
that was my dad to be honest with you
all i'm trying to say is
uh i had a hard life
no no what was what were we just talking
about there was a point to be made
yep it was about the heroin addicts or
something like that the car you've never
taken the train because you're trying to
go no taking a train somebody's done a
joke about this i'm sure but it was
funny to see
like because like you're you're and i'm
sure somebody's done a bit about this
okay but you you could see uh
stereotypes and racism on the train
because like everybody's trying to get
the seat so when you're pulling up to
like the spot where you think that
racial group dave smith has a joke about
this does he do what he's gonna say he
was like you it's basically what you
said you are a little ra you just turn
racist trying to get a seat on the
subway so when you see mad asians and
the d train is one stop from chinatown
everybody just kind of huddles toward
the chinese people because they know
they're getting up right now and i'm
gonna get myself but the funniest part
is when they don't get up and you like
not fronting like you don't live here
bro
you know you live here
wake up were you sleeping i don't know
you got to leave where are you going red
hook stop lying [ __ ] outta here oh
flatbush oh i got the wrong asian i got
a queen
but that that's pushing flushing
flushing my bad
you're right but the i think that we
should be able to ask like on the subway
we should be able to ask people what
stop they're getting off
yeah
yeah that's a great idea
everyone's stop is on your forehead and
body count wouldn't you do that because
you're making a prediction right you're
thinking oh i think you're about to get
off you're in the upper east side you
see the [ __ ] white guy with the
slacks and [ __ ] you're like all right
this guy's definitely getting off at
77th yeah you don't think that he's
going to the [ __ ] broncos
yeah exactly so shouldn't we be able to
yo what's up you getting off at yeah and
then they just tell you and be like okay
i'll wait here that's two stops yeah no
yes or is that too much information
that's a lot of information that is a
lot of it yeah just but maybe if that
was train etiquette like when when you
get a seat you'll be like oh i'm getting
off at this stop so anybody who didn't
get a seat at that time be like okay i'm
claiming your seat you sit down you tell
everybody yo 68 yeah dibs
yeah and then you make eye contact with
somebody oh yeah i got it it's like
calling next at the baseball that's what
i'm saying we call next to the
basketball court what is next if you
live in a nice area they're going to be
looking at you like i'll rob this
[ __ ] right now dog all right
guys we're gonna take a break for a
second because you know what time it is
you already see the lighting okay we're
bringing you the hardest dicks in the
[ __ ] business the true is in
the system ladies and gentlemen more so
ladies
i'm just saying if you want to deliver
the hardest dick you've ever delivered
in your entire life which is what your
wife deserves which is what your
girlfriend deserves which is definitely
with that new chick that you're about to
hook up with deserves you got to have
the true same active ingredients inside
viagra ciaos but this is the chew this
is the one we rock with plain and simple
okay and shorties if you're not getting
that chew dick you're missing out you
gotta tell your man to get on it you
deserve it at least once in your life
and then you go back i like that once a
week and then you're gonna be like i
want that every single night and you
know he'll be able to deliver it because
the chew don't take nights off the chew
is working every single day queens guard
rock hard not phased by nothing
bluechew.com you can get your first
month free all you got to do is pay five
dollars shipping bluechew.com first
month free five dollar shipping
bluechew.com use the promo code flagrant
first month free five dollar shipping
you're welcome let's get back to the
show you don't need to take the train
but now we took the train bro the worst
thing about riding with other people
yeah like you like stand in front yeah
yeah well you're vulnerable when you sit
i don't sit on the train i'm always
ready to fight you you cannot be safer
than when you're sitting on a suburb
i believe that nobody could rob you
you're sitting on the train ready boom
kick
incapacity
your back is to half the train you're
getting [ __ ] up you're back against
the door i don't i don't stand on the
track if that's what four seats in the
hole that's four spots the whole time
yeah don't don't don't ever stand on the
train why you get killed i'm gonna kill
your ass bro
[ __ ] steal on you bro they're not
gonna steal on me
bow nope and then run off the train spit
on you maybe if you're asleep if you're
just on the train sitting down fake
sleeping nobody's [ __ ] with you fake
sleep
that's it you gotta fix it you gotta
fake sleep because nobody's gonna take
advantage of you you're sleeping but
they know you're gonna lose sleeping
just in case for the [ __ ] to
take advantage of you when you sleep
exactly so everyone fakes them because i
get on the train i see mad people
sleeping
everybody's so tired because pregnant
[ __ ] be coming on the train with
their fat stomachs trying to take all
the goddamn seats but if i'm like
then i can do fake snore too yo yo yo
your mom would be disgusted with you
your mom would be remember his mom the
other people didn't get up on the bus i
didn't say she said down the subway was
on the bus that was on the bus i would
never do that on the bus you know
pregnant lady waddling down the [ __ ]
stairs to go to the subway what's going
on here what's up here you just sat down
what are you doing i'm sitting down
but you're awake right now okay
i sit down i cozy up i create my
shoulder space you're not gonna encroach
on me yeah i'm from here do the low do
the demand spread you gotta you gotta
man stretch it out okay just a little
bit a little bit so then you don't
encourage somebody to sit on the scene
exactly why we don't got to share i
don't got to be thought of thought
i sit down like that you know what i
mean i put my phone on my foot try to
look up a girl's skirt
[Laughter]
i'm just looking at your fanny
i'm just looking at your fanny mom
[Laughter]
i was like that's why we need to sit
okay yeah this is really important
but yeah like i'll do some [ __ ] like
that so oh okay you learned something
florida boy yeah
dude what are you doing on the subway
you be staying and doing calisthenics
i try to earn my fare okay i try to
provide value no i always stand back up
against the wall backpack on my front
no you don't no that's the dumbest thing
that's crazy you put the backpack
between your legs my hand under my shirt
like this and i just stared at
everything no the whole time do rag
damn everyone's like where'd you get
that right from like
yes i do i don't wear it around you
white people but if i'm on the train
it makes you uncomfortable when you see
a real [ __ ] with a do-rag but if
i got my hand under my shirt like you
kind of look like
it kind of works but i do i stay
strapped though and if someone tries to
check me i just shake their hand out of
respect
so that's what i do on the train for
protection and it's worked so far you
haven't gotten robbed on the train yet
no yeah but he riding into williamsburg
that's [ __ ] one stop that's true
that's true i've seen other people right
next to me get robbed look just like me
[ __ ] you saw someone get robbed on
the train for real no no
but i would have if uh if they didn't
see me strapped you wanna know a wild
story this ain't that wild
uh but i saw a dude pickpocketing
somebody on a crowded train like i mean
like
super crowded and not a person says [ __ ]
nothing mind your business son it was
there was literally no new york mind
your benefit every seat taken
every i mean the entire train would
float and the dude was literally patting
him patting him trying to get in there
trying to get there i'm watching this
[ __ ] happen because you're more curious
you're like are you going to pull it off
it was the audacity of it yeah the
audacity but also that's the perfect
person to pickpock
pickpocket wait why because they're busy
pickpocketing on someone else they're
not even looking at their own pickpocket
the pickpocket
i got good news bad news you just got
pickpocketed unfortunately for you i
stole someone else's wallet here you go
buddy yeah yeah i said something no you
didn't you didn't i said something i
didn't say it
i just said whoa
whoa you know what i did the other day
he really did that yeah
i feel like he did that too but i almost
didn't think
i got pickpocket once and nobody on the
[ __ ] train said a single goddamn
thing
you know what happened the other day um
when i went to go see thor i'm with emma
okay and these [ __ ] teenagers
dress for minions they show not even
dressed for minions they like these
teenagers were like it looked like one
was bullying another one
and you hate bullies i don't like that
[ __ ] right
i don't like that [ __ ] so like
i walked past it
basically one kid had a city bike and
the other kid grabbed this kind of like
string bag and he kept kicking his city
bike yeah but they were kind of talking
like they clearly knew each other yeah
so i was like okay these kids do like
what what exactly is going on are you
trying to assess yeah but you're a
spider-man though i'm spider-man so i
basically turned around i started to
walk back towards it and they kept
kicking the [ __ ] tire kept kicking
and i'm like
how do i intervene here like what's the
what is that i'm defacing public
it should be property andrew dog
i don't like it but there was there was
like a whole [ __ ] there's like a
shake shack there there's another
restaurant and everybody's like sitting
outside and they're just kind of like
watching this thing go down i just
thought it was kind of weird and i walk
a little bit closer and then the kid who
was getting bullied got off his bike and
acted like he was going to do something
and then the other kid kind of like
ran away but like the fake ran away you
know like you're beefing with your kind
of boy and you're like
she didn't sweetheart yeah yeah yeah
yeah but that i actually
so uh but like
you only had to spend a couple of months
in prison yeah
and he was like stop stop from the
corner yeah i mean he would have beat
the [ __ ] out of you if i didn't you
didn't say stop because i didn't
if i didn't turn style him dude
he traded the fair bro his momentum
style what is the turn you know when you
go on the subway okay but how do you
turn style with someone else i put my
arm there he just went right
that's exactly what i had actually yeah
exactly one bird
one person
but like but basically this kid got off
and the other kid went away and the kid
ran away so they stopped [ __ ] with
him but i thought it was really weird
like there are these they're these kids
are like mid-teens
and this kid looks like he's getting
bullied and nobody even like
yeah but if they're being playful you
probably just think they're friends yeah
you don't want me to do this like what
are you guys doing you're like yo we're
just messing around well that's that's
how i was gonna approach it i went i was
gonna be like i was gonna be like i died
i cut it out like that that's how you do
not assuming the worst either like that
or just be like yo yeah good yeah good
something like that but like like but
the kid getting bullied would still be
like yeah we're good we're good because
he don't want to be no snitch yeah but
you got to see how he answers the
question if he answers scared then you
step in but when the dude got off the
bike who was getting bullied and like
pressed the other dude the other dude
kind of ran away like on some joking
[ __ ] so i was like okay i think these
guys are pierced but i don't know i was
kind of disappointed man like you saw
all these grown-ups like literally
people in their 50s and [ __ ] that have
kids
and there's a kid who's getting [ __ ]
bullied too much risk
because these kids are so [ __ ] crazy
bro you know everybody's crazy and
everybody got guns so you stepped to the
wrong kitty my hazard like well yo on
some level i was pulling that's why i
was like i have to come through like all
right stop joking around yeah because if
i came through like pressing them hard
oh yeah now you don't know what these
kids are up to right now [ __ ] around the
truth
it's everybody no but a group of like 15
year old scares me more than any
demographic on earth about you
a life you know they don't know but you
saw what happened like in the bronx
right who got stabbed to death on the
[ __ ] train platform yeah like he was
15 i think 14 years old yeah
and like i guess he was beefing with
somebody it's on the bro we talking
about manhattan's wild or like the bronx
is crazy right now nobody even talking
about it williamsburg cool
it's like chicago yeah and y'all just
called me [ __ ] two seconds ago
bronx
oh good
talk more about that [ __ ] bro we need a
light foot
um we need a light footage mayor of new
york
she's the mayor of chicago chicago sorry
oh i see okay so what's she doing eric
adams i don't know she's doing that good
no wait do it
can you explain the bodega thing all
right so al you read a little bit too
this guy's name jose alba i think he
works in a bodega before you describe
what happened can you be honest and just
say if you know what happened i've read
we'll see what i retained you know what
i mean
that much i like that
defense it's a perfect defense because
it's like you don't know if he read or
didn't read now he could just not read
[ __ ] nick i guess i didn't retain oops
forgot it i'm i'm a man of honor you
guys are questioning my honor
what are you all through a duel
that true he is a man of honor okay
carry on you you've convinced me okay so
this guy works at a bodega i don't know
if he owns it works there his name is
jose alba and he gets into it i don't
know how what the story is but you see
another guy charge him young kid i
forget his name but he's charging this
this bodega owner like kind of roughing
him up
yeah
so before that happened um uh
mother and her daughter were in the
store i think the daughter was trying to
steal something he grabs the i think
chips from her and then she makes a big
deal about it like oh don't be touching
my daughter whatever oh my boyfriend's
gonna come back and [ __ ] you up
now keep going okay that i did not know
the boyfriend comes back boyfriend comes
back right to him goes behind the
counter shoving him whatever kind of
beating up on him i think the guy's like
kind of pleading with him to stop alba
and then he pulls out a knife at some
point as he gets beaten up and stabs the
guy
bang bang bang guy dies self-defense
yeah and then apparently the girlfriend
was also stabbing the bodega guy she had
a knife also and stabbed him twice but
he's that uh bodega guy is the one that
got sent to rikers and he's the one
that's being on like five hundred
thousand dollar berries being held five
and so i don't get why it's that big of
a story this shouldn't even be a stupid
case the reason it's a big story
the reason it's a big story because he
got punished the bodega guy got caught
so that's because people are acting as
it as we're acting like there's an
injustice yeah the injustice is too alba
the bodega yeah
and it's the d.a like the new york d.a
who's like pushing to prosecute this guy
why
i don't understand son you stole from
the store which does not require you
getting stabbed your stupid [ __ ]
girlfriend
got her boyfriend to come beat you up
you can't discipline her daughter yeah
exactly your dumb [ __ ] girlfriend yeah
who raised the kid to steal and not
discipline her when she steals and not
yeah i don't know who raised us still
free the girl still free yeah that's
also the issue that
larcenous [ __ ]
yeah she's a larcenant you never stole a
piece of candy when he was a kid no but
my boy weimann stole a whole box of
snickers and left me in the boat
i mean i went whining in the bodega he
didn't even say that we was gonna steal
nothing
was that wyman
who later stole from my parents dude
i should have known it too i had no
bro he's the larsen his [ __ ] but
like
we're in the bodega this down the block
from my house mind you it's literally my
bodega i see these [ __ ] every
single day
he comes in the bodega with me he goes
yo check the [ __ ] out i'm like what's up
takes the whole box of snickers
because you know the snickers are in
they just rip open the top they're in
the back takes a whole box runs out
don't say we out nothing just leaks so
i'm like oh [ __ ] i leave can't go that
back to that bodega no more in my attack
you know the [ __ ] block i know bodega
you went back eventually i did
eventually i was like i was that guy
yeah
and then my bad karma was that
[ __ ] stole from my parents yeah
that's what you get my pops gave him a
job did you eat they didn't even need
him to do the job just gave him a job
because he was like you know i don't
want these kids to get in tonight i
needed a job he said so yeah if he's
stealing snickers he needed it no no no
like my dad didn't have a job he
invented a job for the kids because he
wants to help you know he didn't need an
employee
that's what i meant to say because of
andrew his dad got robbed yeah that
[ __ ] stole from us yeah i should
have knew knowing he was like he's gonna
have a snickers bill
did you have one snickers
no
you know what's crazy though is that
like not because it was stolen already
bruh
it don't matter
you could have gone back to the bodega
and giving them like six bucks they
would have paid for all 12 candy bars
bro you want to know something crazy
yeah
when i was younger and and i wasn't
making no money i was boxing at a gym
called mendez yeah
like you're talking like is if you're a
fighter no i do like early fight days
before i made my first purse some of us
have
wrecked
before i did anything and stand up
before i made any money instead of not
boxing it right no use a boxer no when i
was a professional boxer yeah so i i had
a i would go to mendez boxing
and then i uh
i i i stopped going or something like
that i think i was like bro i like just
not i'd like nothing i was like i can't
do this boxing [ __ ] anymore but i think
i owed him a month
of boxing
and uh
i
i was like you know once i make some
money that's a debt i gotta settle
because i i they deserve the money
and um
mendez the guy who was so nice to me and
and so [ __ ] supportive of everything
he died
and you're a piece of [ __ ] that 150
dollars could save his life you're a
piece of [ __ ] what yeah we probably
couldn't make his health insurance how
did he pass away be honest
do you know how he passed away he don't
know he can't go back there
i don't know what he died from i don't
know what he does he don't care either
missing an insulin payment or something
yeah probably
probably just sucks
i'm more pizza because i never actually
paid that money back yeah that's what
you can still make right i tried to i
called them over the phone i asked them
if i could do it over the phone i was
like can i just pay i owe you guys a
month and they're like confused they
don't i couldn't hear you because he was
in a diabetic coma because he couldn't
get his insulin because he needed the
money i tried to be a good person i made
the effort yeah you tried to be a good
person but you made a lot of effort
when you didn't pay for years you were
trying to be a good person no i'm one
month i missed one month
yeah but you didn't pay for how long
right now you go there envelope just
give it to him
but double
and all the months in between also also
with that [ __ ] inflation i did try to
pay i think that's the right thing to do
what happened they said oh you have to
do it in person with the card
i was like yeah i ain't going over i was
like i tried
it's not like he's a comedian making
money getting paid cash
if somebody's inconvenient to give you
money you're not getting money thank you
yeah if you you're like oh i got zell
you're not getting paid accept the money
brother i know i know that's right
i will go out of my way to make sure
they get that well you wouldn't like it
what
the [ __ ] you talking about
out of my way
this [ __ ] not paying nobody bro
this sounded good yeah
mark also cap and mark would pay
everybody no he's a guilty-ass catholic
i want to be in a gang are you going to
be like he's stolen i'm upset at you
[Laughter]
does that bother you like that no
yes it does
i'm gonna use that [ __ ] i didn't know
[Music]
i don't care about any of that [ __ ] bro
i'm hard
i'm hard from the streets bro i'm from
literally brooklyn bk throw it up kings
county you know what i mean
like kings [ __ ]
let's go like i don't care about
feelings or gay stuff
i'm really i'm mysterious